[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'aube des années 50 la chanson
réaliste fait place à la chanson de
charme et de l'amour passion porté au
pinacle par edith piaf le genre traverse
les frontières et des artistes comme
jean sablon charles trenet ou charles
aznavour imprime le mythe durable de
paris ville de la romance et de la
légèreté
[Musique]
il portait des culottes heures des
plâtres de motos inclusion de cuir noir
avec un aigle sur le don ça montre
qu'ils partaient comme un boulet de
canon se mêle à terre dans toute la
région
[Musique]
jamais il ne se voit pas mais jamais il
ne se lavait les onglets plein de
comprimés sur l'islam s'il avait un
tatouage avec un câble sur la problème
est juste à l'intérieur on lisait moment
je t'aime
il avait une petite amie du nom de marie
lou ont la peau nette en pitié
une enfant de son âge car tout le monde
savait bien qu'il aime et entendre tout
sa chienne de motos vignolles davantage
il portait des culottes un des poteaux
de moto un blouson de cuir noir avec un
mec sous le vent ça monte qui paraît
comme un boulet de canon semer la
terreur dans toute la ville
[Musique]
il implora le supplia et dit ne parle
pas ce soir j'avais pleuré 6 buts en bas
mais les mots furent faire du sel heure
de paris
dans la prude la machine est dit qu il
ya des moments comme un diable avec des
flammes dans les yeux aux passages à
niveau ce fut comme un éclair de feu
contre une heure comme à vivre qui
filait dans le midi et quand on
débarrasse à les débris ont tous valls
accumulateurs ses potes de moore
toujours des pires marées avec un aigle
sur le banc mais plus rien d'alarmant
qu'aurait pu rien de ce témoin qui se
mêle à terrain d'hambourg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
passé simple
sari me dire mon soin du monde
à l'espoir soit
jette
faux
[Musique]
je guette à oka
phil raison ce soir passez-vous
ça
au hameau
je vais le dire je vous aime
c'est ridicule c'est beau
ce jeu et c'est triste
c'est
bakou
qui passe est simple
sans me donner espoir
[Musique]
adieu au soir c'est drôle ce qui n'est
drôle à regarder
et là tu attends tu fais la tête moi
j'ai envie de rigoler c'est l'alcool qui
monte en maths est doux l'alcool que
j'ai pris ce soir afin d'épuiser le
courage d'avouer que j'en ai marre de
toi et de tes commérages de ton corps
qui me laisse sage et kim enlève tout
espoir
j'en ai assez faut bien mais je te le
dis du m'exaspère d'une tyrannie
je subis ton sale caractère sans oser
dire que tu exagères ouais tu exagères
tu le sais maintenant
parfois je voudrais étrangler dieu que
tu as changé en cinq ans tu t'laisses
aller tu t'laisses aller là tu es belle
à regarder débattront sur tes chaussures
et ton vieux peignoir mal fermées et des
bigoudis qu'elle a lu je me demande
chaque jour
comment as tu fait pour me plaire
comment ai-je pu te faire la cour est
aliéné ma vie entière comme ça tu
ressembles à ta mère car rien pour
inspirer l'amour
devant mes amis quelle catastrophe tu me
contredis du m'apostrophe avec ton venin
et hargne tu ferais battre des
montagnards j'ai décroché le gros lot le
jour où je t'ai rencontrée si tu te
faisais ce serait trop beau non tu te
laisses aller tu te laisses les genêts
une brute est un tyran tu n'as pas de
coeur et padam importants dont je pense
bien souvent que malgré tout tu es ma
femme si tu voulais faire un effort tout
pourrait reprendre sa place pour maigrir
fait un peu de sport arrange toi dans ta
glace accroche un sourire à tafas maggie
ton coeur et au corps
au lieu de penser que je te déteste et
de me fuit comme la peste essaie de te
montrer gentil redevient la petite fille
qui m'a donné tant de bonheur est
parfois comme par le passé
j'aimerais que tous contre mon coeur tu
te laisses l es tu te laisses
[Musique]
auteur de classiques intemporels depuis
les années 30
charles trenet qu'on surnomme le fou
chantant fait le trait d'union entre le
swing et le jazz
et si charles trenet été le premier
chanteur hip hop français
[Applaudissements]
ce soir le vent qui frappe à ma porte
nous parle d amour mort de devant le feu
qui s'éteint
ce soir
c'est une chance en ôta dans la maison
qui ferait ça et je pense aux gens
lointain
[Musique]
que reste-t-il de nos amours reste-t-il
seconde
une faute
vieilles photos
de ma jeunesse
que reste-t-il des pays d'où
des mois d'avril
rendez vous
ce rennais
or ces
sans cesse
[Musique]
au nerf année
cheveux longs
baisers volés
[Musique]
tu
tout cela
dites le moi un petit village un vieux
clocher un paysage
bien caché
et dans un nuage cher visage de mon
passé les mots les mots tendres qu'on
murmure les caresses les plus pures les
serments font les beaux arts
[Musique]
les fleurs que l'on retrouve dans un lit
dans le parfum aux années veut se sont
envolés pourquoi
[Musique]
que reste-t-il en donne aux gens que
reste t-il
c'est bon vous
non
ma jeunesse
à
restait des billets doux
mois d'avril les roues des roues
un cv
il
aussi sans cesse
honneur frannie
j'ai besoin
mais ces folies
on
st
cela
vu que le mois
une petit village un vieux qu'un jeu
un paysage
si bien caché
et dans un nuage cher et visa
demande c
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh